[Music]
people are calling me cooter beard oh
it's cuz he want me to put glitter in my
beer once you fall in love with the
em-dash good
whoa buddy good well buddy we've already
passed her $15,000 what how are we all
gonna die bill you're not better than
time one two three candle well John just
arrived in the chat so now everybody's
really excited we're gonna be here it's
America how does a ragtag volunteer army
in need of a shower somehow defeat a
global superpower
[Music]
okay going up on my forehead Kendall
turning was a little austere Alex is
everyone happy with that Kitty time Josh
you are you are the McCall's what do you
think of Mars I think there's a cold
dead Rock in the middle of the ocean too
many red demon emojis nasty project for
us and I'm so proud of this community
Humber thanks for our fabulous tenth
ever product for awesome had a great
time I mind uh still a little bit
hungover from it also just coming back I
mean I'm so glad that that's how I came
back to the project for awesome to
nerdfighteria working together to raise
over two million dollars it's still
going on by the way if you want to get
one of those last-minute perks if you
watch this within the first 12 hours of
it being up you can go to
projectforawesome.com slash donate and
get some stuff obviously thanks to
everybody who helped make this happen
everybody who donated everybody who
shared it everybody who voted on videos
everybody who made videos all of the
volunteers who put it all together all
the people who joined us in the
livestream won't wait for the last six
weeks has been really weird I've never
done it before I never left this channel
in almost 10 years of making videos it
was a really weird time to do that I'm
really used to like when something in
the world is going on that I want to
talk about just talking about it it was
interesting to take a break from that
during a moment in which everyone really
wanted to say some things I think it
really changed me and I'm really
interested to see how that manifests as
I get back into making videos you get a
chance to say some of the things I've
been thinking about we got many more
larger donations this year so I'm going
to thank a bunch of those people in the
description we also got a $25,000
matching donation from YouTube as part
of their new creators for Change project
which I will link to in the description
basically YouTube is reaching out with
money to a bunch of different YouTube
creators who are dealing with social
issues on their channel creators who are
promoting awareness tolerance and
empathy with the kind of content that
they make it's a really cool program
link in the description John
so much for doing this with me everybody
thank you for your support of the
project for awesome project for awesome
calm slash donate if you want to get
those last-minute perks John I'll see
you on Monday